what's going on everybody welcome to QA
number ten this Q&A is about hobbies and
procrastination two things that are
often intertwined so hope everybody had
a good holidays I spent some time with
my family came back up here and I kind
of spent a mini vacation in my garage
with my car pretending to be a mechanic
so somebody asked a while ago actually
about the story of my driving the s2000
track
Trekkie - mm or really even before that
I was tracking my motorcycle it's one of
Mines like non-computer hobbies I'm also
scuba certified and I like to poke holes
and paper from a distance just Texas
things so trekking car is not like
NASCAR it's not drag racing it's like a
road course like a squiggly course okay
so it's like f1 racing basically so you
can actually track f1 tracks it's just
in the United States f1 racing is for
whatever reason not that popular we all
like NASCAR for some reason but there is
an f1 track actually in Austin here in
Texas Cota which you could go and track
your car at but it's like three thousand
dollars for a weekend so I can't afford
that anyway and actually I just retired
here we go my helmet
that's from I use that for tracking my
motorcycle which is the first thing
first thing that I took to a track and
then I ended up sliding motorcycles for
dangerous so I got out of the most
motorcycle kind of seen it's got the
s2000 and I've been tracking that ever
since I love that car so lots of time
and yeah this weekend I put up a lift in
my garage I also put in a cold air
intake and a new radiator the old
radiator was fine it was just too thin
and it gets really hot here in Texas and
my coolant was just which is mostly
actually just actually the last coolant
was pure distilled water and it was
still boiling it like nuts so so yeah
because it just gets really hot here in
Texas and you're running your car on the
track and it just gets unbelievably hot
anyway it's not a car channel so we'll
continue along just hanging out here my
garage my 15 year old Honda a lot of fun
to drive around the flatlands of Texas
but you know what I like more than
materialistic things knowledge but those
of you would add blockers that probably
made Bizet's so this next question from
Phillip I'll just call him Phillip how
do you deal with procrastination I'm
trying to switch from my 40 hours a week
in the office to working on my own
startup where I'm my own manager and
procrastination and perfectionism or my
main issues still looking for a solution
these books and advices about time
management discipline not really
helping okay so first of all I guess
I'll work backwards here so first of all
the whole books thing I mean books are
great I would use books though more for
motivation not to actually gleam really
anything too useful so I like to read
books on startups and business and stuff
but at the same time you got to be
really careful not to become a consumer
of a known business which is selling
business ideas or selling kind of like
motivational books that are startup
books so these books are just it's very
close to motivational speaking and you
just have to be really careful that you
don't just become a consumer of that
material you actually use it and
leverage it I'm not saying that you by
any means um but I just I know people
who spend way too much time reading
books and way too little time actually
doing the business because you'll learn
so much more by working on business but
if you read and listen to books along
the way that it can be super helpful and
also just motivating it helps you get
your energy going which then leads us to
procrastination perfectionism so
perfectionism I don't really have a
great answer for that other than
something I mentioned a long time ago
which is basically you know the whole
built where you be crappy you don't
worry be happy whatever whoever you want
to listen to on that one the most
important thing is you ship out whatever
your product is and get feedback from
your users as soon as possible because
you think you know what's best but you
almost certainly don't
now procrastination it can still working
backwards here that's really hard and
that changes over time so initially the
way I dealt with procrastination was I
didn't because initially when I started
I had just lost well okay so going all
the way further back I started my own
businesses I mean when I was like 12 but
I mean this was just like side cash
right at when 12 I'm living at home all
the way up to 18 that was just pure cash
I had no bills and then I go off to
college and I'm making a little bit more
money my parents were helping me so it
was still good enough to just be making
--side cash and my parents started
pulling away money and at that point I
had to get a part-time job through
college and then it was my if I recall
right my junior year in college I was
waiter and the place just went out of
business
one day like no warning I saw it coming
personally but the business itself gave
me absolutely no warning they just went
out of business and sent me a letter
like a day before I was supposed to show
up to work like by the way we closed you
should check great yeah so yeah whenever
people ask me like is it running your
own business like more risky than
getting a job I just I have to laugh at
it because it's like I know when I run
my own business I know exactly where I
am financially and I know what I can I
can predict out into the future but a
lot of people are just way too comfy and
feel way too secure in their job you can
lose your job but like any moment so and
you never see it coming and that because
that's how it's built in that system is
built to make sure you don't see it
coming but before you lose your job or
you get laid off so anyway I digress
so with procrastination for me when I
started I did not have time to press me
I was living not paycheck to paycheck I
was living payment - payment like daily
payments okay that's how close I was and
I was like basically I was slowly losing
money over time and I was there was tons
rather like a week or two weeks away
from being just out of money being
totally broke so that is very motivating
now as time has gone on and I've made
enough money to the point where at least
I can pay my bills now now you have to
be self motivating because because you
don't absolutely have to work you do
have a choice right you could lounge
around or whatever and so it's actually
almost harder once you start making more
money it's easier to just kind of like
sit back so that is where you got to be
self-motivated and a lot of times
they're with procrastination I mean
let's be honest I mean sometimes you
know working 80 hours a week is great
because you can get a lot of stuff done
but at the same time it is taxing on the
body and no different than like if
you're going for 40 hours a week - 80
hours a week let's say on your own
startup you wouldn't try to do that in
any other fields right you wouldn't you
know be someone who you know bench press
is 120 pounds and then suddenly you
decide I'm going to go up to 240 okay
you can't just you can't just make that
change you have to slowly get work
to that point it's really the same thing
with running your own businesses you've
got to like ramp up because you just
you're probably not conditioned to do
that so so yeah there's that and then
also just the fact that you say you're
switched from a forty hours a week
I'm going to guess sorry its whole
assumption phrase but I'm going to go
ahead and guess that you're you've got a
cushion of cash because that's usually
what people recommend like make sure you
don't burn bridges make sure you don't
leave your job until you're totally
ready to and you've got a nice cash
stack to in reserves because you need it
and that's good but also bad because
like I sustained before there's nothing
more motivating than being out of money
so yeah but businesses fail so that's
the other thing is like I definitely
wouldn't want to be out of money until
there was at least a little bit of
traction in some business but anyway
yeah so those are my thoughts try to
think if there's really anything else I
want to add to that but that's about it
so I mean I guess I guess the other
thing too with procrastination a lot of
times you just have to like think about
why why are you progressing is it
because you legit need a break or you
could pay attention other things too
like to run at maximum efficiency you
know your body is a machine so you got
to make sure you've got proper diet
exercise sleep what about stress those
kinds of things so if you feel like you
need to procrastinate the first thing
you should think about is okay how's my
diet how's my sleep schedule how's my
exercise and do I have any stresses if
the answer to all those are no then feel
free to procrastinate because it sounds
like you just need a break probably if
any of those is yet you're still can
procrastinate but while you're
procrastinating you need to solve those
problems like work on the stressors in
your life
fix your sleep schedule eat the right
stuff whatever you don't kind of work
out a plan so at least for me that's
kind of the way what I usually think
about is all I will procrastinate but I
also want to address why am i
progressing right now what why am i
doing this anyways hopefully that helps
if anybody has any more questions for
the Q&A feel free to loom below
otherwise I'll see you in another video